armenian prime minister nicole pashanyan
has won
another term in office after snap
parliamentary elections
official results show his party has won
over 50 percent of the vote
passion yan called the poll to shore up
his mandate after disastrous war with
azerbaijan
last year last year's ceasefire saw
armenia
lose large swaths of territory in the
long disputed nagorno-karabakh region
the election result could impact the
future of the agreement with azerbaijan
the results came in steadily after the
polls closed
one figure was available quickly turnout
despite an emotionally charged campaign
only half the eligible voters cast their
ballot
incumbent nicole piscinian appeared on
facebook shortly after counting started
to claim victory
we already know that we won a convincing
victory in the elections
and we will have a convincing majority
in parliament
called the election in a bid to
stabilize his government
armenia is still smarting from its
defeat to azerbaijan
in the war over the disputed enclave of
nagorno-karabakh
a peace treaty brokered by russia in
november sealed the loss of vast waves
of territory
and that after thousands of armenian
soldiers had died in the fighting
[Music]
the lost war kicked off a wave of
protests with demonstrators
even storming the parliament in yerevan
i want to be able to get up in the
mornings and go out for my exercise
without finding a demonstration outside
on the streets
the last three years have been awful our
economy our politics it's all gone
totally wrong
former president robert kocharian is
heading for second place in the polls
far behind pashinyan's party he's
already cried foul over the result
claiming fraud but that's
unlikely to concern pashinyan who won
international praise for leading the
country to its first free and fair
elections three years ago
and look set to emerge victorious once
more
[Applause]
dw correspondent nick connolly is in the
armenian capital yerevan
nick it looks like with almost all the
votes counted it looks certainly like a
convincing win for the incumbent
nicole pachinyon despite polls that
showed that he was running neck and neck
with his opposition so
how did this happen
well this was definitely a bad evening a
bad election for the
pollsters for the pundits i think you
have to remember that
especially in smaller countries where
there aren't the financial resources for
lots of extensive polling and polling
good polling is expensive
that kind of polling is normally paid
for by one of the political parties that
has an interest
in portraying a certain tendency in
voters intentions
certainly though it was very difficult
to see this coming we spoke to lots of
voters yesterday at the polls
very little open enthusiasm for
passionate i think maybe there was a
a certain unwillingness to kind of come
out with their
support for pashiana after this
disastrous defeat in war to azerbaijan
but still maybe a grudging recognition
that he was the best
alternative the best option on the
ballot so very difficult to tell
but then a surprisingly uh convincing
victory for the incumbent
after lots of months of pretty stormy
politics here in armenia
how's the opposition taking this
well not well is the short answer
they've already said that they
are going to appeal lots of different
results from various polling stations
across the country so far they haven't
brought any examples that would really
change this result significantly they
talk about
pressure from the government on various
members of their political party they've
talked about illegal
um in electioneering and kind of
propaganda by government party or the
ruling party officials
in the days leading up to this election
um whether or not they're actually going
to accept these results is still unclear
both parties both the front-running
parties had said that they would hold
rallies today
bring out their supporters on the
streets of yerevan so there could still
be
some ugly scenes today if it turns out
that the two front runners
are going to bring out their people onto
their supporters on the streets of
uravan
and try and kind of seal this election
with
uh feet on the ground if passion does in
fact come out of this with a renewed
mandate
where does armenia go from here
especially given the fact that tensions
are still running very high
with neighboring azerbaijan
well exactly even if the internal
situation calms down and the opposition
and their supporters recognize this
result nicole pashinyan is
really going to have his work cut out
for him we were up in the mountains on
the border with azerbaijan just a few
days ago where
the border is being demarcated basically
you have
20 year old conscripts up in the
mountains at 3 000 metres
standing off 15 meters from the azeri's
they've been shots fired they've been
soldiers kidnapped there's lots of
potential there for escalation to
continue
uh and you know for lots of people here
they think this ceasefire is merely
a pause uh to this conflict that's been
going on essentially for the three
decades
rather than any kind of resolution and
then nicole paschall will have to deal
also with russia vladimir putin is this
country's
most important ally but he had backed
implicitly
the opposition's candidate robert
kochiran so there's going to be a lot of
diplomatic patching up to do
there and a very tough set of challenges
for this new government to resolve here
in armenia
dw's nick connolly in yerevan for us
many many thanks
you